hey guys who in my private mastermind
group this morning I got a couple
questions asked about video and I
thought the best way to do it was to
make a video response and and I wanted
to also prove a point i'm posting this
video unedited its morning I haven't
shaved I just threw on a shirt I'm not
using any lighting I'm just filling off
my iPad i'm using terrible angle but i'm
still posting it on to my youtube
channel because not every video has to
be the same and not every video has to
be super polished and professional and
way more important is the message and
you being great and you've been able to
get the words out of your face and onto
the camera that's way more important
than how polished video looks and so
there's two people who wrote in with
questions they might answer them both
here quickly today first was Maria who
wrote in to say should I be very relaxed
in my introduction video or highly
professional with a different look and I
think honestly Maria the best advice I
can give you there is to be you you
could spend tons of time trying to
figure out how to be a great editor a
great producer how to do light and how
to do affect or you can spend your time
focused on being Maria and being awesome
and getting your message out and if that
you know that editing and light and all
that is something that you want to learn
you're interested in then by all means
go for it but if it's not then stop
focusing on things that you're weak at
and focus on your strengths and figure
out how can maria be better on camera
because regardless of is professional or
not you can have the most professional
video in the world but if you're not
great it's not going to get any results
where you can have a really crappy
quality video but if you're amazing on
it you're going to get some good
responses you're going to get
subscribers you're going to start
achieving your goals so I'd say figure
out what you want to be figure out where
your interest lies and focus on that and
from knowing you and from watching some
of your videos I would say the more
relaxed look would be more natural for
you would be more personal for you and
just think about that one we do that
you're already posted already got
attention from big companies and people
who are on the Twitter chat that we're
in
then and so I would say do more of that
be more that but again you know at the
end of the day be you do what feels
right next one was do I pick a weekly
topic or just announce my weekly topic I
like having this series I like having
different videos coming out on different
days and having a regular series because
people may come for one video that you
post and if you never post again about
that kind of topic they're going to
bounce but I also say don't always be
restricted to making videos on a certain
day I try to figure out how you can be
more in the moment and post videos that
get you excited and get you passionate
if something happens that you want to
make a video about don't wait until
Saturday because that's video reporting
day make a quick video right now get out
your phone your iPad get a good laptop
and start recording just like this you
know I have my regular series that i put
out in regular days but this is a quick
response I saw your questions that are
gonna make a video right now I'm going
to post it up so it's great to have a
move the topic but don't get so locked
into it that you forget to be in the
moment and you forget to experiment and
try and take on new things especially in
the startup phase of a channel because
you don't know what you're doing yet
right you're trying to figure it out and
so experimentation is really important
and so how many think the topics is
great but also you know staying vibrant
and energetic and doing something right
in the moment as it happens is also
really important to try and then would
it be best of with several videos weekly
out there and promote them the number of
videos that you put up i would say
really depends on how how consistent you
put out great content so on my channel i
have two videos that come out every day
i guess today monday now is going to be
three videos but the videos are good
right I'm proud of the videos that we
make not a lot of people can come up
with that schedule to make two videos
every day and post them up so you want
to be just conscious of not posting crap
and so how frequently can you create
great content that's how quickly you
want to be posting it up and there were
videos that I post
that that may have taken like multiple
takes right I remember when I was
working on my foundation story with my
agent why I started this business
getting down to video I did 30-something
takes of that I made a whole video on it
and be like an eight to ten minute video
send it to him he said no do it again
here's we gotta fix 30 times right tons
of these videos that were posted was
unlisted before I got to the one that
was my you know true story that got out
there that went lied when published and
so as frequently as you can post great
content that's when you want to be
putting it up and that means once a week
then that's once a week but again you
know the more you post great content the
more subscribers you're going to get but
just don't post crap because you need to
keep to a every day of the week schedule
okay next up was rich who had a bunch of
questions about his website enrich all
I'll respond to that privately and send
you another unlisted video but about the
videos he was talking about you all
videos have the same format and I'd say
no and especially you know back back to
poetry you're you're starting up your
channel you don't have a huge base yet
and see you again you don't want to lock
yourself into only doing things one way
because you gotta still experiment and I
look at the videos in my channel still
and I have 50,000 subscribers i have 6
million views i'm still experimenting
right like not all my videos have the
same format I try to keep to a structure
right I try to keep to a schedule where
you know I have my top 10 videos at my
aunt's presso series but even those
totally change like expresso is my
morning video series that comes out at
seven and eight seven a.m. monday to
friday that is brand new that's like a
month old or something and so i totally
changed around my schedule retake the
whole thing after still having a channel
for what six years now and just change
it all around to try out this new
espresso thing and if it didn't work and
i didn't like it i would stop it and go
do something else and so don't get so
worried about having a consistent format
instead focus on producing content that
proud of and you want to explore and try
out and I know you're all about
inspiration inspires your word and so
you need to be inspired right and if
you're always locked into doing the same
thing each time I think you'll lose that
inspiration pretty quickly that's what
does intros on each you have
introductions on each video um I would
say no and here's what I've done with it
an introduction I think of two things
one of me saying hi eleven Carmichael
and here's what I do and the other is
having a logo and at the start I did do
a lot of hi I'm Evan Carmichael here's
what I do and then I started watching
some some channels as the big one was
Casey nice hat and he never says what he
does he never says really who he is in
the intro like it comes out in the video
and and he's got tons of subscribers and
tons of views you know a lot of these
videos get the hundred thousand views
overnight and then get through millions
and I found it interesting like when I
am the guy who has a million subscribers
am I gonna say hi I'm Evan Carmichael on
each video and I was thinking probably
not and if you want to be that guy who
has a million subscribers and you got to
start acting like the guy who has a
million subscribers and so that's what I
started to do I just started having the
confidence and with each video I'm
looking at it and making it feeling like
I already have a million subscribers and
taking on that mindset and i so I found
that that really helps me in my videos
and so I've taken out I don't say Who I
am at all on any of my videos I don't
think pretty sure I don't and then the
logos I like using different logos with
different types of videos and this is
something that is pretty brand new and
something that experiencing with but
every video will have my logo and almost
everybody this one isn't because
but we'll have the airplane coming out
and has believe and all that and then
I'm trying to make a branded logo intro
for each series that I have so the ants
presto series in the morning has its own
logo as well where this is a coffee cup
that comes up and the smoke is coming
out and you hear the rooster calling
because it's supposed to be morning and
so I'm looking at making a new logo
intro for each of the videos that I have
last up was how do you post youtube or
blog what's the sharing process so my
process would be to post to youtube and
then embed that link on your other
sources so if you want to put it on your
blog then don't just upload the video to
your blog put it to youtube and then
embed it on your site with facebook what
i do is a little bit different where you
have two options you can either link it
to your YouTube channel right you can
post a link to your facebook page or
your personal Facebook with a link to
your YouTube video or you can upload the
video natively to Facebook and what I've
been doing more now is uploading the
video natively to Facebook would you
figure out is what is your goal if your
goal is to get as many YouTube numbers
as possible then you want to upload the
video to youtube and just link it in
your Facebook page but if your goal is
to reach more people have a bigger
impact then it shouldn't you shouldn't
matter this on youtubes on facebook
somewhere else is just trying to have
the reach then upload natively to
facebook the reason is if you upload the
video to facebook then you're going to
get more views than if you just share a
link to a YouTube video because the
Facebook guys they don't want you
leaving they don't want you going to
youtube they want you just put the
videos on their own site so they rank
that higher so that's what I would do
post to youtube and if you really want
some big impact then post it to Facebook
as well natively and on your blog embed
the video from your YouTube channel and
this last question was water inspiring
sir what are interesting video topics
for us to watch what I'm curious about
so on your channel you know you have the
motivational videos you've done the
interview series I'd love to see more of
you and I know you're all about inspire
I love
no what inspires you and you know maybe
it's little things I could go to the
park with your son and he does something
it down as far as you or maybe you read
a blog post or watch your video that
inspires you or maybe you're sharing
some lessons from a famous entrepreneur
or famous photographer videographer and
that inspires you I'd love to know a
little bit more about the man behind the
camera and I would continue the other
series where they continue doing the
motivational videos I continue doing the
interview series and I try to make that
consistent I try to have a schedule that
people could get used to so you know
every saturday morning the new interview
comes out because if i sign up for an
interview you know if I if I subscribe
to your channel 41 kind of video and
then you stop doing that or it's
inconsistent I'm probably gonna
unsubscribe so I try to keep those
videos consistent as long as you enjoy
doing them as long as that's still part
of your flow and what you love doing but
then it also add in a new series talking
about you things you're going through
your thought process a message that you
have to inspire people because i think
that i had so much more personal element
to it and you're much more likely to get
clients and subscribers when they can
see the guy behind the camera so is my
quick thoughts i'm going to post this in
a mass I'm dupage continue to believe
have a great day I'll see you guys soon